[Música]
e
hola qué tal bienvenidos una vez más a
esta emisión de canadá de las américas
café el programa semanal que les propone
el servicio en español de radio canadá
internacional en castellano se porque
hay un debate nuevamente sobre ese tema
evitamos problemas de estamos con esas
imágenes que veíamos de distintas
ciudades de canadá y con el equipo en
pleno aquí presente hoy estamos aquí en
el estudio paloma martínez está el mes
pablo gómez barrio
el vengador enmascarado el señor
increíble
y tenemos en el otro extremo de la mesa
un invitado que es manuel ribeiro un
artista que nos viene a hablar de un
evento que va a ocurrir este fin de
semana en la ciudad de montreal y del
que vamos a estar dialogando en algunos
instantes más mi nombre es luis laborda
les doy a todos ustedes la bienvenida
les recuerdo que pueden seguirnos por
distintas plataformas de hace ya tiempo
ya estamos de hace mucho tiempo en
nuestro sitio de internet www
net punto sea y también en nuestros
canales en vivo de facebook live ya que
se recuerden
en el canal de youtube por donde
esperamos que muchos de ustedes nos
estén viendo en este momento como están
todos ustedes parece demasiado bien
porque es fundamental de la alegría
nunca se está demasiado bien si no se
está bien aquí adentro
el clima nos está pegando y estamos
hablando del día de muerte si estamos
vivos y vamos a hablar mucho de los
muertos hoy al mar y casi entero va a
estar dedicado a ese tema hoy y
precisamente ya que manuel lo dice
arrancamos el programa hablando de la
celebración que aquí se conoce en
américa del norte como halloween y en
otros lados como día de brujas que es un
evento que ocurre todos los años más o
menos en esta época del año en red hacia
fines de octubre
que terminó ayer y este año vino con
disputas vino con discusiones visto vino
con condenan con debates y con enojo
en las cosas interesantes entonces
debatimos por la diciéndose medio cínico
con el tema no porque realmente la
discusión vamos a poner en contexto el
tema para nuestro público el 31 es decir
ayer debía llevarse a cabo la jornada de
halloween propiamente dicha
mostrando en las afueras sobre todo
exacto que cuando los chicos los niños
los pequeños y a veces no tan pequeños
salen a recorrer los distintos barrios
disfrazados diversas ciudades en canadá
y en toda américa del norte pidiendo
golosinas a los vecinos pero ayer había
una alerta de tormenta severa con
fuertes lluvias y con viento muy intenso
por lo cual las autoridades decidieron
suspender que esta jornada o postergarla
por algunas horas
pasarla para el día de hoy para el
primero de noviembre
esto se hace un dato anecdótico que creo
que no debería enojar ni molestar a
nadie aunque es cierto que a mucha gente
le puede producir algún trastorno genera
un debate que hizo que hasta los medios
de comunicación ayer estuviesen
debatiendo si estaba bien o no postergar
la celebración del día de halloween a
ustedes los afectó a mí me afectó la
salida del trabajo no la
la postergación de halloween sino los
medios de transporte en común porque
porque es el metro estaba parado una
intervención médica en el metro 45
minutos esperando después que el tren
llegue el tren tarda y el tren se rompió
así que yo tenía que salir de halloween
y yo supongo porque era una fecundidad
de terror
justamente fue un día de terror hizo
saltar el hombre increíble
este trastorno se produjo este tema del
mundo
aléjate de que afortunadamente para mí y
para la mala fortuna de mi querido
leonardo el tren el metro de la estación
de metro aquí cercana que esta estación
podría que no estaba incluida en ese
daño en ese problema que hubo en el tren
que se suspendió el servicio a partir de
barry camps estaría en griñón en la
línea verde es mi línea es la línea
verde salvo de que me voy para el otro
lado que es honor en boca
entró y el maestro llegó sin ningún
problema cinco minutos más tarde por ese
lado no hubo ningún problema por el lado
de la postergación de la fiesta de
halloween pues me dejó un sabor amargo
no para nada en absoluto ya mis hijos
están muy grandes entonces ya no pasan
el halloween lo que sí recuerdo es que
cuando mi hija mayor estaba muy
chiquitita que yo viera tronar o
relampaguear ese roce nevada
el halloween se llevaba a cabral y
salíamos y no había absolutamente
ninguna excusa válida para que no
saliera con ella a recoger sus bombones
entonces pues sí me sorprendió un
poquitico que se hubiera postergado la
cosa pero en realidad verdaderamente yo
fuera
niños pasan los niños pasan alrededor de
las cinco y media comienzan a pasar
hasta las siete y media máximo la lluvia
fuerte comenzó después de las siete y
media y los niños latinos salen más
tarde
pero en general pasan un poquitito
después de llegar de la escuela en
cuanto sea oscurecer comienzan a salir
por tu barrio hubo movimientos o no lo
que pasa es que estamos esperando que
cayera el apocalipsis como nos lo habían
anunciado porque hubo sectores de
montreal en los que si los chicos
salieron a pedir por ejemplo el barrio
de la salud
también se ha cancelado con la estela es
la montreal y se hizo ahí
me dio mucha mucha pena porque hay una
familia que recién hace tres meses están
aquí en en montreal son sirios y era la
primera salida de sus hijos y salían las
22 disfrazadas todos mojadas con un
paraguas chiquito halloween
y decir que había gente que salió y que
venció los besos la naturaleza se opone
nosotros la venceremos dijo simón
bolívar hubo gente que no se dejó
amedrentar en lo más mínimo y se las
ingenió para guarecerse de alguna manera
o para usar algunos de los implementos
que para esta época del año aparecen por
todos lados aquí en montreal y en buena
parte de canadá para poder estar al
abrigo de la lluvia y de esa manera
poder cumplir con el rito de salir a
pedir las golosinas en la noche de
brujas en el día de halloween y hay un
vídeo tal vez nuestro compañero pierre
puede poner el vídeo para mostrarnos qué
es lo que hizo esta gente de que se
valió
hay una tienda y un abrigo de esos que
se usan para abordar los los autos en
todo esa época del año en muchos lugares
nieva intensamente en pesos esos abrigos
impiden que los autos queden cubiertos
de nieve en la noche sobre todo y no
tener que paliar la nieve para sacar el
auto temprano a la mañana cuando hay que
ir a trabajar y esta gente entonces lo
que hizo fue tomar ese abrigo
para cumplirles sobre todo a los mil
niños por lo que hemos terminado
asociando es que en américa latina no se
siento el país espero en argentina
puntualmente existe el día del niño el
día del niño es donde uno agasaje a los
niños donde deba ser regalos golosinas y
tortas
y aquí no hay el día del niño como tal
entonces es como el día del niño es
halloween es salir disfrazarse compartir
con ellos ir a pedirles dulces y eso es
todo es toda la ceremonia lo interesante
y si no se puede hacer ver no es bueno y
para estas fechas los que se divierten
no son solamente los niños también los
adultos se divierten sí y hay un desfile
también tenemos un vídeo que le pedimos
a pierre que lo ponga de un desfile que
entrega este vídeo ya lo tomé yo hace un
par de años es creo del 2017 que es el
desfile de los son
es todavía dentro de una semana eso se
lleva dentro se lleva a cabo dentro dos
días efectivamente por esto es una que
esto es una grabación vieja de años
anteriores porque el de este año todavía
no sucedió pero bueno esa es la el
festejo que llevan a cabo los adultos
que también se divierten a lo lindo
porque hay que preparar esa escenografía
del maquillaje porque he olvidado los
desfiles y ha salido a la calle y de
repente los encuentras en el metro por
la calle de noche no dan miedo así dos
miedo
luego aparece una producción muy
interesante no son disfraces uno se pone
una máscara y listo
ahora si participamos y maquillaje
están muy logrados
y hablando de zombis que son de estos
muertos que vuelven a la vida aunque
creo que ahí está en vivo que tienen
mensajes y antes de eso yo solo quiero
leer los mensajes de la gente que nos
acompaña en el camarín y dice hoy es el
día de todos los santos mañana el día de
los difuntos saludos desde munroe buenos
aires espera el trampolín y dice lo sé
bien porque es mi cumpleaños
lo que quería decir feliz cumpleaños
saludos antes gracias a mi departamento
de cerro largo en uruguay gustavo lucro
nuestro stop fan miriam alarcón también
top fun dice feliz cumpleaños daniel y
gustavo dice a luis no se lo veía hace
tiempo
danielle que aquí por suerte no existe
existe halloween
bueno en realidad son privados y miren
genial
esa idea de cómo no se nos ocurrió antes
dice felices
esos son los mensajes
hablando de zombis que en definitiva son
muertos que vuelven a la vida y hablando
de muerte o vivo y dices las tiran de
muerte
pero tenemos a manuel de primeiro de
invitado que es un artista de origen
mexicano que participa este fin de
semana de un evento muy importante que
se lleva a cabo aquí en la ciudad de
montreal y que no es la primera vez que
se realizan de manuel y bueno la
tradición precisamente pasando del
halloween a lo que nuestras nuestros
pueblos
festejan es realmente el día de muertos
y como decía daniel creo es el día de
los santos inocentes del día de los de
los niños que mueren después de los
adultos
que es el primero y el día 2 y el día de
los angelitos le dicen en la costa
colombiana así es y en méxico tenemos
una tradición de hacer lo que llamamos
el altar del día de muertos en donde
tradicionalmente ponemos un altar en
nuestras casas en donde agasajamos a
nuestros muertos a la gente que se nos
fue de la familia y ponemos siempre los
alimentos la foto de la persona la
música que le gustaba
80 muy bien retratado en la película
coco realmente ha hecho que esta
festividad se conozca más en todo el
mundo así es así es este y que de hecho
ha llevado un poco un poco más de
seriedad y regresar un poco a los
orígenes de inclusive del halloween que
era el festejo del solsticio y del
harvest aemet cetera no que tiene que
ver con los ciclos de la vida y demás
más que con una fiesta este en donde se
va a pedir golosinas nada más no esté
entonces si es el cuarto o quinto año
que el consulado de mexico a través de
espacio cultural méxico de lo que damos
espacio méxico organizan el altar de
muertos el este año lo estamos haciendo
en el shot dejar de mover al que el
cambio que era antiguamente la
biblioteca de montreal que es un espacio
padrísimo enorme con una reserva que
éste va a estar de hecho ya está ahorita
desde las 12 del día hasta las 78 de la
noche hay un evento a las 5 para ver van
de muertos porque le llamamos que es un
pan que se es muy parecido a la rosca de
reyes pero con una forma distinta con
unos huesos
este condicionalmente en estas fechas
entonces siempre hacemos normalmente
algún tipo de talleres en los invitamos
a la gente a que participe con nosotros
para adornar este este altar y
tradicionalmente lo hacemos en en
homenaje a dos personas a un artista
mexicano que nos dejó este año y a un
artista que bq a que por ejemplo en años
pasados fue leonard cohen y juan gabriel
este este año del indio fernández y no
me creo quien más este año es él
[Música]
francisco toledo que fallecieron este
año nos dejaron y tratamos de llevar el
homenaje a estos dos personajes
principalmente este año además se quiso
hacer un homenaje a otras dos personas 1
a million portis miguel león-portilla
exactamente y a al antiguo cónsul
general de méxico en montreal
jaime garcía mar al porque porque él fue
el que fundó espacio mágico el espacio
cultural méxico y es un poco el homenaje
a este esfuerzo que se hizo y que nos ha
dejado un lugar para vivir nuestras
tradiciones latinoamericanas porque el
espacio médico a pesar de que pertenece
al consulado
siempre nos lo prestan por ejemplo en la
cámara de comercio- latinoamericana
ahora estamos hablando del debate
hispano y precisamente la parte la tiene
a corta con todo el debate porque
incluye a todos este nos lo prestan para
hacer nuestros eventos entonces es un
agradecimiento muy fácil espacio méxico
que hay que aclarar es uno de los
motores más importantes la difusión de
la cultura mexicana aquí en canadá pero
no solamente mexicana es ya
una institución de difusión cultural
latinoamericana ha realizado
innumerables exposiciones está
continuamente impulsando eventos de tipo
cultural en las más diversas formas que
tiene la cultura de lo literario a lo
plástico etcétera etcétera y ha sido uno
de los impulsores de este evento en el
cual vos participaste además también
como artista propiamente preparando algo
de lo que se va a ver en ese en ese
altar asia es lo que vos elaborarse
bueno lo que yo hice fue una mariposa
monarca hecha de papel maché hay una
técnica que se papel maché pero en
méxico se usa mucho para hacer lo que le
llamamos los alebrijes que son seres
imaginarios un poco de colores muy muy
muy locos entonces decidimos hacer un
alebrije de una mariposa monarca porque
de una mariposa monarca que es muy
interesante para empezar este año
también usamos papalotes lo que llamamos
cometas en castellano en mexicano en
español mexicanos y los papalotes porque
el papelón interna le dicen
con metas y cometes creo que el nombre
del más el fundi sea falso
el asunto es que papalote en agua que
quiere decir mariposa entonces hay un
lazo interesante el francisco toledo
cuando mcdonald trató de implantarse en
la ciudad de san cristóbal de las casas
le parecía una grosería que en un pueblo
este mágico
tradicional hubiera una cosa comercial
amarilla y entonces el protesto
precisamente volando papalotes entonces
es un símbolo un poco de toda la obra
artística de francisco toledo hicimos
unos talleres me da mucha emoción porque
remigio valdés el director de espacio
médico me dijo oye manuel vamos a hacer
papalotes vamos a hacer 400 para palos
quien nos va a ser tú vas a animar el
taller y lo vamos a hacer y habíamos
previsto que lo hiciéramos durante un
fin de semana
así es anteayer que me intoxiqué con la
pintura
bueno este es y la verdad es que
estuvimos trabajando hasta como las 3 o
4 de la mañana pero es muy padre ahora
es un proceso que además el alebrije
dicen que uno no decide qué hacer el
origen el alebrije no lo escoge a uno
entonces se deja uno llevar un poquito
por las cosas de último minuto decide
cosa entonces y terminamos muy tarde
pero en fin lo interesante aquí es nada
más para terminar con con fresco toledo
es hicimos 400 papalotes en cuatro fines
de semana aquí tengo la lista de
agradecimientos no la voy a decir por
obvias razones está bastante largo
selección alrededor de 30 personas pero
éste por lo menos quería mencionar por
allá a algunas personas a lorena a
marilyn a cecilia a cristina que
cristina tiene 45 años
festejando día muertos acá en montreal
en este y hablábamos de que la paloma
hablábamos de que las jornadas centrales
precisamente hoy comienza alrededor de
la tarde se extingue hasta las 7 va
haber un evento en particular a las 5 de
la tarde que es lo que la gente que
asista va a poder ver y hacer hoy va a
haber un homenaje a nuestros dos
artistas escogidos a franco toledo este
ya a los al cónsul general ya ya miguel
león-portilla y ya más el finado y
además va a haber una degustación de pan
de muertos hubo otro taller organizado
también por espacio méxico en donde se
fabricó el pan de muertos entonces la
verdad es que es muy interesante porque
todo esto viene del de la gente que
participa con nosotros y les quiero
decir había mexicanos había colombianos
había argentinos había este la verdad es
que es muy muy paridad que adecuada
tenemos a una chica suiza que habla
español que llegó allí de repente dijo
yo me enteré y vine entonces muy padre
había gente que pasaba en frente del
espacio méxico nos veía pasaban con los
niños decían que están haciendo estamos
yendo papalotes y así podemos participar
adelante nos fue muy muy padre
quería decir que francisco toledo en
otras en otras ocasiones que es un gran
artista mexicano en otras ocasiones
utilizó los papalotes para hacer otras
protestas digamos cuando hubo la muerte
de los 43 estudiantes mexicanos en el
estado de guerrero
poco después francisco toledo organizó
otra manifestación con papalotes en la
calle y hermosas fotos de este de este
artista con otros manifestantes con
papalotes en las calles entonces fue eso
es digamos una herramienta que él
utilizó siempre para protestar a través
del arte leamos de hecho no estoy 100%
seguro porque creo que alguien nos había
prestado un papalote de francisco toledo
iba a estar en la exposición el día de
hoy y luego no veamos puede hacer 400
papalotes funcionales con el viento de
ayer
acortamiento de hoy
definitivamente no van a estar están en
una instalación están colgados del techo
entonces
por otro lado también eso es parte de la
curaduría de remigio es tratar de hacer
del papalote una guía acuérdense que
estamos hablando del día de muertos y de
toda la tradición y del camino de las
almas de los difuntos hacia el más allá
y el papalote también lleva ahí una
simbología de cómo de qué es lo que nos
guía hacia el inframundo no es las
mariposas también bueno y ahí entre lo
de las mariposas que queremos hacer la
mariposa monarca pero además es un lazo
que une canadá y méxico que ve aquí
méxico porque la mariposa monarca fue la
migra de canadá a méxico en un viaje
impresionante para un animalito tan
pequeño en cantidades
muy muy grandes y cada vez menores por
eso también la obra que está ahí que
hicimos tiene una cara de mariposa pero
de una muerte también porque estamos
tratando de demandar otro mensaje que
escuchamos y no son forzosamente las
mismas que regresa hay una parte que
queda en el viaje porque es una vida
relativamente efímera de hecho quedan
allá las que regresan son las reales las
crías y otra cosa este bien interesante
de la migración y de todo esto que está
pasando es que tratamos de usar no
tratamos usamos material reciclado para
todo lo que hace al mismo entonces este
por ahí les mandé unas imágenes pero
estamos hablando de usamos en cajas de
papitas de papas fritas todo todo lo que
es empaque y lo recubrimos de papel del
papel periódico de papel de cartón de
caja
en vez de pegamento blanco usamos
engrudo que es hecho con maíz
claro yo quería volver a lo que vos
nombraste más noble acciones te manuel
que son el tema de los alebrijes porque
me llamó mucho la atención incluía
algunas imágenes en nuestro sitio de
internet la gente que acceda después a
nuestra página va a poder ver algunas de
esas imágenes y la información que yo
tengo aquí es que es una artesanía
inventada por pedro linares lópez en
1936 es decir es una forma de expresión
que ya tiene su tiempo de existencia y
que se lleva a cabo tomando en cuenta o
participando la técnica de lo que es la
cartonería que es la cartonería en
méxico
bueno la cartonería original fue traída
de china a italia por marcopolo por las
primeras expediciones este de ese tipo
es lo que se llama en italia el
cartapesta alcanza peso que es las
figuras las más caras
de cartón y después se llevaron a españa
y con los conquistadores en américa
latina y es lo que se usa para las
piñatas por ejemplo no antes una piñata
original está hecha de hojas de papel
que antes era tela también se usaba este
listón de los vicios de la vieja y con
engrudo con engrudo de harina de maíz
este con agua entonces es algo muy
natural que pega y que dura mucho tiempo
no este es básicamente estar durante
horas y horas poniendo capas de
periódico de papel
3 es les puedo decir yo los talleres los
hago a mí me encanta hacerlo porque es
como que un momento en donde dejas de
pensar
realmente y el proceso este del alebrije
que les decía que el alebrije es el que
te encuentra no leyó la primera vez que
tomé un taller de alebrijes con el
maestro morales que es un maestro
escuela en morelos esté muy muy
interesante su técnica y decía yo quiero
hacer
un dragón mes ya no lo entiendes tú no
decides qué es lo que vas a hacer en el
alma del alebrije te va a encontrar
entonces para mí toda esa parte y eso
viene aunque aunque pedro linares lo lo
concretizó de alguna manera la idea de
los alebrijes viene de mucho más atrás
viene de los pueblos indígenas que
trabajaban en la madera el copal y que
lo trabajaban de esa manera de ahí se
inspiró pedro linares que era cartonero
que se ayudas y hacia asia piñatas
meditativo pero no aburrido
la palabra meditativa a veces es muy
contemplativa es un momento bien
justamente una de las terapias para las
personas que tienen depresión trabajar
con las cosas manuales así que supongo
que este tipo de cosas debe también
relajar y canalizar energía no un
trabajo recomendó entonces para los que
queremos apaciguar algunos pensar
y alegría dirige a la visión como dueño
son figuras extras son en parte reales y
en parte fantásticos por eso uno de esas
imágenes tan cierto en la ciudad de
mexico de alebrijes gigantes y mariposas
que no son mariposas porque tienen parte
de mariposas y de otros animales lo que
no se sabe bien quién son porque también
ahí la imaginación se echa a volar el
pensamiento reposa pero la imaginación
vuela al conectar figuras no es cierto
la imaginación y un poquito es
conectarte con y ahí es en donde yo sí
entendí muy bien lo que decía el maestro
moral es decir es que te encuentras tú
estás trabajando con algo que no tiene
forma básicamente es un pedazo de papel
y empieza y de repente le ves forma o
sea dices mira me están quedando así y
de césar bueno aquí tal vez le pongo
esto parece una mano entonces también le
continuó esto parece un pico esto parece
una cola esto y empiezas a hacer algo
qué
y conforme más te lo imaginas más dices
no ya ya esta imagen ya la tenía de
alguna manera no no no sé cómo pero es
algo y todo eso se hace también cuando
ahí hacemos talleres los padres que
estamos trabajando estamos platicando
estamos con música de repente estamos
platicando de repente nos quedamos
callados y todos trabajando durante un
par de horas y de repente otra vez
alguien empieza y bueno y eso dar cuando
hacemos los talleres con puros adultos
además los compañeros con un mercalito
así y yo aquí tengo algunos algunos
mensajes dice luis y éste es paragón
ilícito es un buen periodista y también
un fantástico profesor de español
saludos 15 de louise bourgeois
miriam alarcón dice decimos volantín en
tucumán en vez de papalote que idea
genial dice 400 son muchos éxitos a
manuel y después tenemos homero
mendizábal dis en praga hay un gran
evento del día de muertos este primero y
2 de noviembre con talleres comida y
música atencional de méxico vale la pena
asistir la gente lo hace con mucho
cariño para que conozcan la cultura
mexicana y latina ángela sierra dice
maravilloso manuel ribeiro al público de
montreal los esperamos a partir de las 4
en no mencione este y perdona angela
pero traigo que mi lista gracia mientes
estate
quiero organizar particularmente al
conseguir es darle moral que nos prestó
el lugar al organismo de las masas y al
latín arte que precisamente latinarte
nos ayudó con la curaduría también a
angela que siempre está implicada en
todo tipo de iniciativas
latinoamericanas en el mes de la guita
es latinoamérica en la casa de las
américas de la cual es la directora
etcétera no perfecto y manuel quería
preguntarte para quienes no conocen o
que no conocemos me incluyo
estrechamente la cultura mexicana desde
afuera muchas veces uno cree que méxico
existe una especie de
a tracción demasiado fuerte por lo que
es la muerte pero por lo que venimos
hablando queda demostrado que esto no es
así en realidad de lo que se trata es de
una vuelta a las raíces de recuperar el
recuerdo de aquellos que se fueron y de
rendirle un homenaje a la propia
historia mexicana a través de un
recuerdo aunque sea efímero de quienes
ya no están pero que ayudaron en su
momento a construir lo que hoy es méxico
y no es cierto así es fíjate qué
interesante que lo digas porque creo que
mucha gente dice que no no le tenemos
miedo a la muerte por eso mucho yo creo
que al contrario le tenemos tanto miedo
a la muerte que nos reímos de ella para
tratar de quitarle un poco los nervios
lo que sí decir no es un acercamiento
morboso no no lo es es extremadamente
respetuoso inclusive y creo que además
lo leí en algún lado pero me hace mucho
sentido bueno nuestras culturas
indígenas
y americanas tenían una relación con la
muerte muy natural no era como es parte
del ciclo es regresar a la tierra
no teníamos esta y creo que es una
mezcla entre entre nuestra nuestra la
conquista española y un poco la cultura
este judío crystal creek cristiana que
adaptó un poco esa manera de pensar
entonces nos quedamos con esa parte
natural pero por otro lado con el miedo
de la muerte con entonces es igual para
el que no lo vivió sufrí una vez hace
dos años atrás a la típica que se
presentó bien y dentro de todo el
proceso de la muestra de la típica se
hace un altar y se hace la ofrenda y
realmente es precioso o sea yo soy
argentino no lo conocía tuve el primer
contacto con eso con ese festejo entre
comidas y es realmente emocionante y uno
ve a la gente llevando la imagen de sus
muertos para recordarlos y alguna cosa
que le hacía recordar alguna
no sé alguna comida que le gustaba mucho
al abuelo y es súper llamativo y es y es
muy sentido
yo no lo noté en ningún momento ni como
de risas ni como una burla ni como un
acercamiento a la muerte ni no como una
cuestión morbosa ni negra no una cosa
realmente muy especial y muy sensible
con la gente que lo está yo soy la
muerte ese es el lema venir a la típica
de este año el año pasado creo que era
el camino de las flores este año la
típica es yeso y la muerte y el título
es así en mitad en francés y mitad en
español porque ellos querían señalar en
ese aspecto y el camino de las flores es
porque es porque normalmente
tradicionalmente en los altares de
muerto en méxico ponemos flores de
cempasúchil que es la flor de la
calabaza que es naranja que es el color
de la muerte el naranja y el morado
este gel y 9 disfrazado de zombi
y además se hace es riquísimo se come
pero adorna también nuestros altares no
entonces y bueno no sé si además de
título demás se han comido este flores
de calabazas forex lo tienen que hacer
es muy rico manuel para cerrar el tema
por el momento pero aunque no te vas te
quedas con nosotros quieres recordar si
lo tienes en la mente la dirección del
evento que se va a llevar a cabo hoy si
es en el concepto de modelación
biblioteca de montreal en el edificio
gastón llegó en el 12 10 de sherbrooke
este a las 5 de la tarde se enfrente el
parque la frontera en la esquina
al público en general de montreal los
esperamos a partir de las 4 en el
consell de sau de moral para la ofrenda
así que el pan de muertos tenemos
también un saludo del leónidas dos
santos nacimientos
y saludos de brasil y felicitaciones
todo equipo buen trabajo muchas gracias
y lo dije los están todos invitados
entonces voy a participar en este evento
y te invito ahora a leonardo a que le
recordemos a nuestro público la
aplicación móvil de radio canadá
internacional así es la aplicación
ustedes pueden bajarla desde las dos
tiendas más importantes que hablando de
la tienda de apple de la tienda de
google ponen rs y español o si quieren
bajarlo en otras lenguas en inglés en
francés en chino o en árabe pueden
hacerlo bajan yo estoy haciendo la
promoción por el español baja en español
y ahí tienen también el acceso por la
gente que hable español en canadá por
ejemplo probable es muy probable que
hable inglés o francés o quizás los dos
entonces a partir de nuestra aplicación
también puede acceder a las noticias más
importantes de las otras dos lenguas las
lenguas oficiales así que los invito a
ir a las tiendas a bajar nuestras bicis
sí señor y también les recordamos como
lo hacemos habitualmente que les pedimos
que nos envíen fotos videos del lugar en
el que ustedes residen para que quienes
no tenemos la ocasión de pasear por toda
américa y por todo
donde tenemos público podamos conocer un
poco más de cuál es el sitio en el cual
ustedes llevan a cabo su vida un oyente
preguntaba o decía hace un tiempo que yo
estuve ausente desde hacía ya un rato y
es verdad porque me tomé unas vacaciones
de un mes
buenos aires- que mi ciudad volví
después de 10 años a caminar por esa
ciudad de las que le traje algunas
imágenes un reencuentro con mi ciudad
que fue para mí muy emocionante y
conmovedor un reencuentro con amigos un
reencuentro con las raíces allí estamos
viendo entre otras imágenes de este
pasaje con una muy con una frente de una
casa pintado de señora
eso es en el barrio de palermo pero una
de las cosas por las comunas de
actuaciones por las que elegí esta
imagen es por qué
a las ciudades buenos aires tienen de
este tipo de pinturas este tipo de
expresiones artísticas por toda la
ciudad siempre se ha visto en buenos
aires pero no tanto como ahora allí
tienen unas imágenes que también me
resultó muy muy impactante que es una
foto que saque en lo que es el tigre en
la zona norte del gran buenos aires- esa
imagen es una recreación de un pasaje de
la historieta el eternauta de ostras el
que es ambientada en la época de la
dictadura militar en la argentina y que
tiene allí un mensaje muy claro para
quienes en algún momento pasan por
alguna sensación de desesperanza hay que
apoyar al héroe colectivo que es el que
siempre lleva la sociedad adelante y una
imagen que me gustó también de una de
una vista de lo que es buenos aires
desde lo que se llama el jardín japonés
que está en el barrio de palermo un
lugar muy muy bonito que existe hace
muchos años y que hoy creo que está
mejor que nunca me encantó volver a
buenos aires que estoy
muy contento de haberme reencontrado con
mi ciudad de hacer más vida no voy a ir
muy seguido de hecho estoy planeando
estar allí en pocos días más en una
decisión que todavía no está adoptada
pero buenos aires y la argentina inician
en pocos días más un proceso político
que somos muchos los que esperamos que
le devuelva al público argentino a los
argentinos en general y a todas las
personas de buena voluntad que quieren
habitar el suelo argentino como dice la
constitución del país el bienestar que
ese país jamás debió perder es muy
triste ver en una ciudad como buenos
aires en una megalópolis como de buenos
aires con toda la cultura que tiene con
toda la arquitectura que tiene con toda
la solidaridad de la que son capaces los
argentinos cuando quieren mucha gente
que está viviendo en la calle en este
momento que no tiene techo mucha gente
que no alcanza a llegar a fin de mes con
sus salarios para comprar lo básico para
subsistir esperamos que el proceso
político que se abrirá en poca semana
más el 10 de diciembre pero en todo caso
poder estar allí también
la alegría con el resto de mis
compatriotas cambie una vez por todas la
historia del país y que no se vuelva
nunca más atrás que no se vuelva a las
divisiones que han dañado la vida
institucional de la nación durante tanto
tiempo y que de una vez por todas los
argentinos puedan tener el presente y el
futuro que se merecen en un país que no
es nuevo decirlo esto no soy nada
original pero es verdad tiene todo para
hacer mucho más de lo que es y no pasar
jamás por crisis económicas ni por
momentos de angustia como los que está
pasando mucha gente ni recuerdo para
todos los que están en situación
difíciles de argentina mi solidaridad y
espero todos los pronto esperemos que
las cosas vayan para mejor en el futuro
cercano bueno ya nos anunció luis de una
forma subrepticiamente de que se va a
ausentar otra vez que se vive en este
momento un momento de efervescencia en
la argentina como yo lo viví cuando el
país salió de la dictadura militar en el
año 83 y llegó la hora de fonsín al
gobierno ese momento de cerveza
y ahora está de alguna manera volviendo
y es realmente interesante vivirlo y el
amigo social me gustaría estar allí
tenemos acá más saludos en este caso a
mano decirle a leónidas que no quería
desde ningún punto de vista
hicimos acento que tiene el portugués
que me encantaría hablar lo que
lamentablemente no lo hago es solamente
puedo imitar la caída y pablo duarte
también supongo que habla portugués buen
trabajo amigos desde el sur de portugal
este amigo siempre lo sigue pablo ruiz
de matos duarte así que un abrazo
también para le decimos gracias nos
quedan solamente seis minutos así que
los invito a todos ustedes a que le
presentemos al público los temas
destacados en los que hemos estado
trabajando durante esta semana
comenzamos por paloma si te parece bien
sé qué es lo que te sugeriría el público
que vea en primer lugar que vaya en este
fin de semana o que es ya en su defecto
vean mi reportaje sobre el salón de la
muerte a un salón de la muerte tiene un
nombre un poco fuerte lo discutimos es
un poco fuerte pero conversé con
mauricio ramírez que es uno de los
organizadores de éste
evento y que decidieron ellos el grupo
de organizadores llamarlo así llamarlo
por su nombre justamente para para decir
estamos bien con la muerte es una parte
de la vida y tenemos que enfrentarla
tenemos que hablar de ella entonces
invitan a la gente a celebrar la muerte
de alguna manera en este en este evento
hay es exposiciones hay conferencistas
hay para niños y para grandes también se
les habla a los niños de la muerte se
les explica la muerte entonces si
quieren escuchar una entrevista con este
organizador del salón de la muerte pues
ahí se las presentamos en www.ccm.es se
pueden probar los ataúdes
se trata de dormir por una eternidad
porque de una forma una manera u otra y
ahora lo que sí es que también hay
opciones tecnológicas y ecológicas de
morir y allá en el salón de las
presidencias de morir
como decía un amigo sin pensar que voy a
morir no es nada pensar todo el tiempo
que voy a durar muerto se necesita algo
como una crónica tecnológicamente usted
cree que cultivar
cuestiones alimentos de manera ecológica
es bueno para el ecosistema no nos
parece que no así que van a verlo porque
este artículo va en contra de todos los
mensajes que estamos recibiendo de coma
más sano porque encima de comer más sano
que tampoco es en realidad tan sano está
cuidando el planeta que parece que
tampoco sería la idea así que vayan a
verlo el sábado
pablo come barrio pues y ya que estamos
con la temática mexicana
entonces la extensión universitaria de
la universidad nacional autonoma de
mexico en gatineau y hace este año una
ofrenda monumental bueno de hecho que
comenzó el 31 de octubre y va hasta el 3
de noviembre esa ofrenda monumental es
en homenaje la temática de la ofrenda es
en conmemoración de los 500 años de
mestizaje no tiene nada
no está relacionado de alguna forma pero
ese es la típica es la muerte igual
entonces la
a estar esta ofrenda es una ofrenda
monumental que fue fabricada por
fernando trigo profesor de artes en la
escuela moderna americana de la ciudad
de mexico yo hice una entrevista con él
y
los invito a escucharlas ahora también
ya que estamos hablando de muertos los
invito a escuchar la entrevista que hice
con uno de los organizadores de la
típica 2019 je suis la muerte que como
verán la muerte es la fijación de la
emisión de hoy de la semana entera
y de refilón pero el tema que yo también
le propongo abordar puede ser que esté
contactado con la muerte también está
haciendo una gira por canadá una
militante social colombiana se llama
isabel zuleta en ellas del movimiento
'ríos vivos' y está aquí presente en
canadá recorriendo distintas ciudades de
la costa oeste comenzó en los últimos
días de octubre en vancouver y se viene
para montreal en las próximas semanas
para concientizar a los canadienses
tanto al público como las autoridades
sobre el daño que está produciendo un
megaproyecto hidroeléctrico
hidroeléctrico perdón que se llama hilo
y tango hidroituango
ha provocado que una porción muy
importante del territorio colombiano
haya sido inundado y es que ha provocado
en la población de esa región del país
un doble daño porque los ha desprovisto
de sus tierras del lugar en el que
vivían y producían pero a su vez del
lugar en el que se encontraban
precisamente sus muertos y una de las
cosas que se hizo fue inundar una parte
del territorio y esa inundación se llevó
por ejemplo el cementerio del lugar esta
militante isabel zuleta está denunciando
la situación y porque aquí porque canadá
y que ve que inclusive a través de la
caja de depósitos inversiones son parte
de quienes financian de ese proyecto en
colombia y ella pide que canadá se
retire ese financiamiento y revea su
postura respecto a emprendimientos de
este tipo en américa
no nos queda más tiempo nos han puesto
ya la cortina para avisarnos que nos
tenemos que ir despidiendo les
agradecemos a todos ustedes el haber
compartido con nosotros una emisión más
de canadá en las américas café esta
emisión de la sección en español gracias
nuevamente a manuel ribeiro gracias a
paloma a leonardo a pablo a mí
que sigan todos bien a superhéroe